hello and welcome back to reality check
it is time for the final episode of this
three-part special all about the science
of prey fear is primal in the wild it
serves as a protective mechanism
allowing animals to avoid predators on
other potential threats for humans fear
is more complex that said we've all
experienced it whether it's before an
important test confronting some jerk on
a Friday night or that panic when you're
absolutely sure you've lost your wallet
only for it to turn up in that pocket
that you never use why do you even exist
pockets as bad as these fairly mundane
fear experiences can be though put
yourself for a moment in the shoes of
praise central character you are trapped
aboard Space Station Talos 1 and you are
definitely not alone hostile alien life
is in abundance some mimic their
surroundings meaning almost anything
could be a threat and others are
actively hunting you
so how would being in this situation
affect your mind on your body well
that's exactly what we're going to find
out in this episode in short imagine
that you are Morgan you do I get it
I think one of the first things that
being hunted would do to use it would
increase your vigilance so we talk about
hyper vigilance and this is basically a
state where you are tuned in to threat
it's a little bit like having a smoke
alarm at your house turned up to
sensitively so it's a little bit better
at detecting when your house is on fire
but it's an awful lot better detecting
when you're burning toast so you will
have a a threat response which will
increase of low pressure which will dump
adrenaline into your bloodstream at a
much lower threshold than somebody who
is less vigilant welcome back to Mark
Coulson their longtime reality check
fans will recognize mark from many
previous episodes of the show so being
hyper-vigilant as he put in what would
be the impact of all that biological
response and would it actually be
helpful one of the first things that
happens when adrenaline gets dumped into
your bloodstream is you lose a lot of
your fine motor control so if you're
performing a task that requires
precision and accuracy you'll be less
effective at it that's because one of
the main effects are something like
adrenaline is to give you effectively a
boost to your explosive power the
purposes is fight-or-flight but if you
want to do something intricate then
pressure is generally a bad thing
ah so if you need to quickly escape from
that alien chasing you down or bash it
to a pulp with a wrench then yeah that
would help however if you need to hack
your way through a security door or
operate a computer in order to escape
then perhaps not your fumbling fingers
just might be your doom
fighter flight though is not the only
impact of fear one of the things that a
stressful situation does is it tends to
narrow our attention so we're much more
focused on the particular details that
we might need to respond to so if we
make you anxious in the laboratory then
you will actually be better at certain
kinds of tasks which for instance might
include picking out a threatening face
in a crowd but it comes at a cost so by
not paying so much attention to the
periphery to what's going on around you
you might miss various opportunities you
might have
a weaker understanding or perception of
the global situation so this might make
you better at spotting threats like I'm
sure that chair just moved or wasn't
there just one mug over there before
however it may make you less good at
paying attention to the layout of the
station for example resulting in you
getting lost and putting yourself in
needless danger as interesting as it is
to hypothesize about how being in this
prison might affect you
ultimately though we'll never really
know because none of us will ever be in
that situation
and playing the game is just not a real
enough experience or is it when you play
a game like this you will have real
physiological and biological responses
to the events your palms will sweat your
heart rate will increase adrenaline may
start to interfere with your ability to
use the controller as you lose your fine
motor control you will find your focus
of attention narrowing you may find your
perception of time altering as well this
is a real experience and in the sense of
course you're your real physical
existence is not being threatened so you
might say they're far less terrifying
than experiences we might have in the
real world but on the other hand we
don't have those sorts of experiences in
the real world ok now I want to finish
this episode by focusing on just one
aspect of what makes praise such
uniquely tense experience the mimic
aliens these guys rush around and mimic
objects of roughly the same mass that we
bump into crucially though they do this
of their own accord they are not
predetermined to be a specific object at
a specific time all we know as a player
is that they tend to mimic nearby
objects so if there are two of one thing
next to each other then we should really
watch out so what impact does this have
on us then there's any possibility that
we might be able to predict what's going
to happen but we're not sure then we
will tend to get anxious and stressed so
if a particular alien always pretends to
be a coffee cup that ceases to become
exciting or interesting because we learn
that extremely quickly the key thing
there from a games design point of view
is to ensure that the aliens are only
sometimes coffee cups and sometimes
something else and sometimes they're not
there at all
hmm so the key then is to be
unpredictable
that is interesting I love the the
McKeon's and pray because I think
they're not ridiculous that's the thing
which is so strange something which is
able to copy an item so so specifically
we find creatures like that on earth
already so when you think of the masters
of camouflage
everybody says chameleons and everybody
is wrong cuttlefish are a zillion times
better chameleons
yes they can change their color but
they're doing it via hormones that's
slower your blood stream is only ever
moving at the red here blood cuttlefish
use neurons therefore it is the speed of
electricity they have got chemicals that
respond to light all over their body all
over their tentacles this means it's
almost as if they're seeing and
responding to their environment with
their tentacles
moreover cuttlefish have got rings of
muscle in strange places allowing them
to take on the texture of their
environment it's not just that has got
the right colors it's got the right
texture
it's an extent the right field
cuttlefish are the masters of camouflage
well that's it for this three-part
reality check special all about the
science of prey you can watch all three
episodes right here on gamespot and if
you have any questions ask away in the
comments box below or of course you can
reach out to me directly on twitter at
camp Fras Rob I hope you've enjoyed this
mini return to reality check and thanks
for watching
[Music]